hey guys thanks for tuning in so I
thought it was high time that I did an
actual workout on this channel again and
so today I'm gonna be showing you a pecs
routine that you can do entirely with
one exercise that being the press up
[Music]
okay so the workout is going to be 100
press ups 10 slow press ups arrest 10
rocking press ups on either side 10
clapping press ups and then arrest we're
going to repeat it again so you'll see
how it's kind of like a circuit I talked
to you a bit more about it as we go so
[Music]
the point of this video is me to show
you a workout you can hopefully use
yourself that we use for as a way to
train your pecs pyla is also to teach
you three principles or concepts that I
found really useful in my training and
that hopefully you can apply it to other
workouts yourself as well the first of
these is that you should be doing more
press ups in your routine press ups are
wonderful so the reason I say this when
I first started training I had no idea
what I was doing that about 10 to 13 I
just started doing exercises in my room
I had no couldn't excessive hair very
light dumbbells so 99% of was doing was
press after just did tons and tons of
process that didn't really fast on the
floor and I saw throw best and I really
enjoyed having a toned physique and you
know being at school quite strong is
cool for a kid so I stuck have it and
that's a part of the reason that I'm
still working out today but as I got
older I started to integrate more and
more different ideas and actual concepts
and I started to learn about how to
train correctly I joined the gym etc you
know usual stuff so I started to change
the way I've trained but to begin with I
was always still doing the press ups
because that always worked for me I
didn't want to mess it with the formula
that worked then as I got older I
started moving away from that slider so
to spend more time at the gym doing the
bench presses and the curls etc but I
start to forget about those press ups
and then I start to notice that my gut
was starting to get a little bit less
flat and defined and at first I put this
down to age I thought you know I'm
approaching 13 now my metabolism is
slowing
that's just the way it is welcome dad
bottom Oh first rest if you can't do
hundred pesos that's fine
just fifty with Jesus fine just
twenty-five fifty just fine
the point is it's whatever you find
really difficult and on my next day
round I'll probably only be able to did
sentence five or fifty that's a good
thing then I was looking and thinking
what else has changed I realized the
precipice of change I wasn't doing the
press-ups anymore so I try to
reintroducing those into my routine to
see if that would make a difference and
it did I start to find myself turning up
again in my stomach becoming flatter and
mine energy levels going up so what is
it about press-ups that makes them say
leave useful was a couple of things
firstly press-ups train the transverse
abdominus that's the ring of muscle
around your stomach area that supports
your organs it keeps your stomach pulled
in
it also supports your spine when you're
doing heavy lifting and yes because this
holds in your gut in your organs I can
actually make you have a flatter stomach
tone leave you lots of press ups at work
too much like a plank you're trading
that core you're holding yourself steady
flat like so and so you're training the
transverse abdominus stomach gets a
flatter and more tone than if you were
not doing anything to train the
transverse abdominal then you might miss
it the press up to makes a very big
difference the other reason the first
opportunity of any big difference to me
is because the way I was training them
was just really really fast you know
when I was younger I just deal 100 or
200 because it's cool with telling
technique what this meant was I was
actually doing the form of concurrent
training or resistance cardio so I was
doing the form cardio exposed to me long
enough exercise that I was using my
aerobic system but it was also a form of
resistance training because I was
pushing my own body weight so it was a
concurrent training resistance car yet
and that such as one of the best ways
you can burn fat and turn up because
you're burning of using a lot more
energy to keep going like that then you
would be if you're just doing cardio
it's like running on a treadmill that's
on an incline it's like running through
water or in sand or it's like punching
against cables that holding you back so
anything like this can be a really good
way to burn more calories than you
normally are but I've been lazy
it sucks this is a good way for me to
increase my calorie burn during a
workout especially compared to just
sitting there doing benchpress wherever
which is basically lying down there's a
lot more active and it burns more
calories and then the third reason that
it makes difference because I was doing
it every single day are still in process
on top of whatever other workout I did
and frequency it turns out to one of the
most important things for seeing gains
for burning fat for changing your
physique and so by just adding on what I
was doing was like 300 press ups on
three sets of 100 on to your workouts
then you're increasing your frequency
the chest into the ABS and they're
burning more calories and you're so just
increasing your energy expenditure and
it's a very explosive form of exercising
before we like that biometrically and
then that means you're increasing your
ability to observe energy as well the
other concept I want to teach you is the
idea of being able to do a full workout
on just one station or using one
exercise in this case the press up so a
lot of us can go to the gym you want to
make it as interesting and it's dynamic
as possible and that's great so you have
this long list of things we want to do
all these kind of weird different
exercises and we go through and we do
them all problem is within queueing wait
for the weights become available with
walking backwards and fours across the
gym we're setting things up we're
unsetting them actually takes a lot of
time and about 50% of that time spent
exercising the 50% is spent with setup
and resting and everything else well you
can do instead to just go into the gym
and grab one station and work an entire
routine basically that one station so I
went through is on my go to the cable
cross machine if I'm certain biceps set
it down low so I'm just curling the
cable and then I might do a bicep curls
that I might do hammer curls with
different attachment overhand curls I
might change the way I can get faster I
might change away slow and go low in
this slope
if extra credit you can try just holding
that last repetition there for as long
as possible good luck
if you find you get to 80 or if you're
doing 1514 you can't do any more then
one way you can carry on it's a form of
mechanical drop set drop onto your knees
and be precise on your knees and I
combine all this into a single workout
and actually that is enough variation
and also just really hitting those
biceps with very little break in between
you get a great workout just from one
station so here I'm going to show you
how you can get a great workout just
from press ups and that's a really
useful exercise to be able to build a
whole chest workout out of because it's
an exercise you can do anywhere and it's
incredibly convenient exercise so if you
can get a whole chest workout just for
me this then you can trade anywhere
without having to set up loads of
equipment etc
[Music]
[Music]
like what if you can't do any more late
so I just do little jumps on your hands
I actually think that press ups have one
of three exercises you need to train
your entire body using just bodyweight
training you have this big pull-ups and
bodyweight squats so I might look at
workouts I can do using those later
so the third and final concept I want to
show you is how you can use Joe Weider's
style intensity techniques to make even
an easy exercise into a very difficult
workout so press up to something that
most of us have mastered by now many of
us will do hundreds of presses before we
get tired and that's why a lot of us
have kind of abandoned them but the
reality is and that if you are more
creative about how you use your
exercises and how you include those
different variations you can make even
an easy exercise into a difficult
workout so we're doing things like we're
changing the tempo or were slightly
changing the order or we're not having
the brake wave normally would do and
then this inhale you're doing really
high repetitions quickly that the
hundred or two hundred is a kind of
flush there's a burn sense great way to
build up metabolic stress so basically
I'm gonna show how you can make a great
workout afternoon very simple
yeah
[Music]
the ideal length for a break by the way
is around one minute two minutes at an
absolute maximum depends on how intense
will make me work out how hard you're
finding it etc of course you can do a
team like this with all manner of
different exercises if you want to work
the upper pecs and shoulders and you
might want to do some decline press ups
so they do you've got that downward
angle
[Music]
as you can see I was struggling even
just with that if I was gonna go round
twice more you'd start to see me
struggle more and more and I'd have to
lower the number of repetitions I'd
probably bit off slightly more than I
could chew they're trying to show up
lowered slightly and do you see what you
can do okay say doing 50 15 25 a spine
or so you can do account the drop set
until I stop to get past failure by
talking on to your knees but carrying on
for instance or by going from clapping
press up to just minor jump in press ups
etc so yeah let me know what you think
about this if you find it useful and
interesting then please leave a like
maybe share maybe subscribe and I'll
keep you posted I've got a lot more
exciting stuff on the way as usual on
bodybuilding fitness on productivity on
brain training etc but every workout
coming because that was requested by an
awful lot of people we'd be doing more
on Bruce Lee because I always seems very
popular and I've got some some slightly
different and hopefully interesting
stuff on the way as well so yeah stay
tuned if you'd like to see all that
thanks so much for watching bye for now
[Music]